don't worry that's pretty good pen  that's a good pen I'm gonna earn you  going crazy he got them old ones he  still couldn't work love to see it no  no and no honestly what is it about  Chuck with like his golf swing  everything's just so like robotic you  know Chuck I mean I didn't think it  could get much worse but it did to be  honest I Gotta See Shaq this is the one  I want to see oh my god oh that's a big  toe kicking the ball why are they all  toe poking it poor ball oh he slotted  the second one though I just love shack  they really need to work on the  technique they got the toe ball going I  think they could improve we got Kenny  right here oh no no no no no no no no no  no he's gotta go I'm sorry but he's  gotta go  oh no and that looks wrong on so many  levels Kenny Kenny kicking like he don't  got any more bones in his body I don't  know what's going on  oh like if you give me a basketball I  can shoot and then you can see this  horrendous